and going on massive winning streaks but
recently the recent tournaments I can
only go back to San Luis and topple los
winning the World Championship as as so
impressive as what we're seeing here
very very nice performance by the
Italian American the modest Italian
American and tomorrow to recap tomorrow
we've got Nakamura playing weight
against Fabiano Khurana can he win yet a
fourth game against the Phenom in this
tournament
I'm Levon Aronian playing against magnus
carlsen Levon will have the white pieces
and then Veselin Topalov
playing against Maxime washing on the
grass so you've got the two highest
rated and the two lowest rated playing
well not anymore of a pre-tournament
Levon and Magnus are the two highest
rated right and there is a trap I see
that these grandmasters they're tricky
vessel and has just played the move
Knight to c5 setting up a very very
nasty trap you can't play the move
Knight d4 because bingo we're in a King
and pawn ending where blacks blacks King
is going to be able to come across the
board I swim across the board and
actually elbow White's King assigns the
King important games and when the e3
pawn and win the game okay to just rely
on intuition and when you you're getting
tweaking upon a game right no no no King
and pawn and games are very very
practical so you need to make sure to
you triple double check man it's like
double triple rather something and of
course here you don't need a lot of
checking ninety four is not okay and
did not play it instead he played an 8
to a 3 check exactly sites taboos
meanwhile Fabiano Khurana has played a
mover to age 5 as expected and I think
that is going to that move rook h5
specifically I think that's going to
induce a handshake I don't see LaVon
playing the move rook f7 and asking his
opponent to demonstrate rook h7 that
it's not necessary Maurice your thoughts
actually there is another funny line
involving the Knights again trapping
those nights that will have to be found
by Khurana the move Knight to d8
attacking that pawn trying to get it
directly is possible and after the move
rook check you can also queen right away
but let's just play the check first king
here attacking the rook and now the
simplest move little surprising is to
actually promote to a queen let me get
that on the board and now Knight takes
all right my mouse is arguing it wants
to be used and now the will rook to g8
and look at those Knights again and one
of them will clearly be taken off the
board and once a night goes it's going
to be the exchange and two extra pawns
and resignation there's no way this is
going to be continued so a cute little
move and that'll be it so it's over and
he has in fact indeed we have a
resignation and officially Fabiano
account starting with four out of four
in the Sinquefield Cup the strongest
tournament in history what are we gonna
do guys we just got to applaud right
young man has impressed us to the point
that we're like wow we're in awe or
seeing something absolutely phenomenal
that's right Bravo Carolina aka mr.
perfect all right and have we have the
players agreed to draw in Magnus's game
doesn't look like an impact
international arbiter Chris Berg just
tweeted are they really gonna make me
give them another set of score sheets Oh
apparently yet those we just saw in the
webcam
these two are determined King verse King
perhaps well I mean vessel and I
understand wants to make absolutely sure
of everything so a lion where he was
winning well exactly would have required
a massive blunder right but I think what
we're about to see is this night whites
night pardon me going to f2 and then
going to h3 capturing this pawn on g5
yep and then capturing this part of you
that is what happened and I think you
know unlike that by the way even though
everybody knows it's it's they they both
know it's a draw to play it out for the
spectators so the spectators a couple
nights for good measure
okay so you know there are no meeting
chances anymore a hard-fought well
played game with topalov wondering I
think he actually asked did I miss the
wind
I know yes do you see his face he says
to do the honors it looks like Magnus
data for you
and more and well there were see five
right well I don't know if it was rook
c5 so much as I think Veselin after
shaking hands saying did I miss
something and Magnus said yes I think
you should have played this and the eyes
went I had that opportunity and
immediately Magnus knew that he had
overstepped the bounds of this game
keeping track guys and I don't recall
the computer going crazy for any move as
we were going through the game so I
think it was that moment with work c5 I
did it was right here
what loop number is that sorry well I
can do it on my screen sorry I don't
have to it was
let's see we're getting we're getting to
it we get into it we certainly movie
going over it and it was the move rook
takes a fight and I believe Magnus was
saying I was afraid of rook c5 right
here right now if you know that yeah and
then the eyes of Topol off lit up and he
said oh my god I didn't see that because
of course the point is that if after the
capture that night or none viii is
bereft of squares which is something
that we've we've seen in a number of
games today those trapped pieces right
that's that coming up again and again
it's like we have a themes of the round
and if rook c5 if the rook was forced to
move away for example to anywhere along
the eighth-ranked to say g8 then that's
the whole point there's no real take c6
and the a pawn on a5 is lost for free
and vessel and just simply miss rook c5
and I think we did too we we skirted
past this precise moment but Magnus
recognized immediately that he had gone
too far and the moment has passed
top olive has regained his composure he
seemed a little bit upset there for just
a second and he's in shock it's all
smiles hey well he's just like I used
gifted he was gifted a half-point let's
put it that way
meanwhile we're gonna start getting our
guest set up for the interview starting
with Grand Master Levon Aronian um I
just saw the audience there and again
there was Mike Magnus thinking what kind
of tournament am i having he's just
taking his head in disbelief well Lucas
true that but then again if you think
about it in a certain manner so to speak
he got a Magnus position a position that
he wanted to bump and grind for as long
as he possibly can
and he
you only succeeded in avoiding losing as
opposed to even getting close to a win
so so something is not clicking with
Magnus Magnus is not having his brand of
playing his brand of chess well we heard
more about that in a minute but now
we've got grandmaster Levon Aronian and
he is with Maurice Ashley with
Grandmaster Levon Aronian number two in
the world of the official ranking but
now number three in the world things
have not been going so well then you you
played it your main rival over that
number two spot wait some speculative
chess to be sure it looked like you were
more or less okay what happened this
game well I mean I knew this line more
or less I mean 92 looks like playoff art
of space I had to say and I thought my
position is great I saw exactly in this
moment I could have played 93 and it
bishops e3d sequin III roopd 8 it looked
very exciting for me but then for some
reason I just stalled and then my
position started getting worse because
you know it's also psychological when
you don't do the move that you were
planning and you lose the opportunity
you start kind of blaming yourself and
also the position maybe it's already
slightly worse for black were you
surprised when he sacrificed the piece
for two pawns he had this maneuver
Knights h2 to g4 that would have seemed
seemingly put some pressure but suddenly
he sacrificed and just played a pretty
unclear chess giving the position yeah
yeah it was surprising but I felt that
after night h2 I might be okay because
I'll sacrifice the exchange would rotate
for after 94 and then probably luck is
fine so I thought it was a strong
sacrifice and getting a some kind of
real play look like it was very
difficult for you to defend then I've
long time control ive laundered 15 gauge
7 ridiculously of course I should play
Queen e8 and the position is very
unclear what's your objective assessment
of how Quran is playing right now uh
well today I thought he was playing
strangely but maybe it's a part of
preparation
well 92 was of a prepared move we shared
out Sherman's coach at 9/8 who was
prepared but just in terms of his play
me he's either played great preparation
great defensively as he did against
Carlson when he was attacked now sort of
maneuvers and then speculative against
you it seems like he's really grown as a
player yeah I thought you know the
position more tonight it may be I mean
it's I didn't really analyze this I just
felt that it's very natural for black to
play but after I didn't play 93 I think
he didn't make mistakes so he played
very well
final question the situation in the
tournament I have asked people before
he's sitting on four points they're the
closest player is the robit - and the
rest of you are at - one is the
tournament over hmm
well I mean if I if I am Magnus keep on
I mean not winning and I mean also the
other guys it will be very difficult to
get with a piano so I guess the
objective for the players will be to win
against Fabiano so everybody's ganging
up on him okay well thanks so much thank
you we wish you the best in the rest of
the games
thanks guys back to you thank you well
objectively stated yes if Fabiana
doesn't lose and he's gonna win the
tournament
maranatha has already laid down his
intentions for against Fabiano and
nobody's talking about it so let's start
talking about it absolutely well that's
what it's gonna take
because obviously Fabiana is a man on
fire they'll still have you'll still be
massively ahead of the field I mean it's
well as Maurice described it he's
lapping the field at the moment
I mean it's early but four rounds is
remarkable you can't make this up how
can you be two points ahead after four
rounds it's raining I mean
he just recently broke that 2,800
barrier you know he's gonna be sitting
in like 28:20 well I don't even want to
try to guess what is TPR tournament
performance rating is so far I mean a
million yeah three thousand this is one
of the most amazing Grandmaster Fabiano
Carolina getting set up for his
interview with Maurice Ashley we don't
usually do this but I do want to keep in
mind for viewers that if you hashtag
sync up we might occasionally be able to
work one of your questions into the back
so enjoy the commentaries and thank you
to all of the people who tweet actually
yes that's true yes many top
grandmasters and he's here mr. perfect
semester Fabiano Carolina when can we
stop calling him that he's with Maurice
Ashley to talk about yet another win
thanks Jen with the number one player in
the tournament that is we're gonna
debate the world maybe a lot of fans out
there debating that question but we're
with Fabiana Caruana
who has four points after four rounds
you said you're a decent chess player
are you upping the self-esteem a little
bit now
well the tournaments going great for me
and I think I'm playing pretty well so
I'm very satisfied with it I'm trying
not to get ahead of myself
well it's our job to get ahead of
ourselves
sorry we're running out of superlatives
to describe your play today's game seems
very quiet you played this move 92
you're your coach was saying that you
guys prepared that little move to all of
us it looked like not much but you
worked it into a good position well it's
a very complicated position I I was I
mean there was a game um Carrick and
Dominguez sorry Dominguez karyakin and
and 980 was a new move we had found it
some time ago I decided to play it today
it's it's not a huge novelty but it's
least a very interesting game it's very
complicated double edged I can also take
over the initiative but I think I played
accurately
he shouldn't have allowed my queen to
get to age five after that it was just
very very difficult for him he can't
really do much and always has to watch
out for tactics and at some point I've
tried to play h3 Knight h2 but but when
I saw an even better idea with Maya day
five I I went for it and after that I
think it was probably very difficult for
him to defend maybe just losing you
played this move Knight a5 like you said
it looked like Knight h2 was solid cool
how did you feel when you saw this
sacrifices you think well I'm winning or
it's just interesting with lots of play
and I'll just work my magic
well the problem with night h2 was I was
worried at some point after a g4 he'll
play rook F or give up the exchange and
get a lot of dark squares and I'd like
to comes to c3 and I didn't want I
wanted to to play I wanted to sacrifice
myself and I thought I have a big
advantage I wasn't sure if I was winning
or just much better but in any case
practically I thought it's very
difficult for him to defend now our guys
are looking at this and saying four and
Oh after four rounds okay that's one
thing to have lack the field people are
one person standing at two and everybody
else had minus one we've never heard of
it how do you feel being in this
situation it feels pretty good yeah I
didn't expect it at all and but I mean
I'll take the wins as they come now you
have a very difficult matchup against
Nakamura tomorrow he has expressed great
confidence in playing into in fact when
we asked him how are we gonna how are
you guys gonna stop Fabiano he said well
I just have to beat him I have a good
record against him what are your
thoughts there he's a very good player
and it's true that I don't have the best
score against him but recently we've
made a lot of draws I don't think I've
lost two against two minutes in about a
year so I'll try my best tomorrow we'll
be watching with bated breath for sure
congratulations on your fine start and
there's the luck in the rest of the
games Thanks our leader in first place
grandmaster Fabiano Caruana playing like
a world beater right now at four no guys
back to you how sweet it is
doesn't get any better does it and we're
going to get set up for Magnus will be
coming in shortly and topple off and
before that let's take a look if you're
a little bit more about this Nakamura
roni on we've got the 960 man the end of
the event remember right exactly
here we're talking about that earlier
that's gonna be a rapid match right in
960 and the idea is well think about
Bobby Fischer said shuffle the pieces at
the start of the play and that way the
starting position theory is tossed out
and the best player wins and the idea is
that there are 960 positions that are
quite quote legitimate which allow for
castling the kings in between the rooks
and so on so as opposed to calling a
Bobby Fischer chess a you would call it
chess960 right people could have used
both interchangeably right some people
say Fischer or some people say 960 will
probably switch back and forth during
our commentary as well because part of
the cool thing about the match is that
it's partly in honor of the synergy
between the world chess Hall of Fame and
the thinking with chess club Bobby
Fischer exid's yeah and so forth back at
your exhibition across the street which
Tarin showed us earlier in the show
right and just another reason it's not
just the chicken wings and Alejandro and
then Feingold and Ian and Barth also a
little bit of chess history and of
course and there was a specific book
that I just wanted to make sure that the
viewers in the audience understood what
she was talking about before his match
in 1972 against bought Boris Spassky
there was a book in German that came out
to parties of Boris Spassky which was
basically all of the games of Boris
Spassky and Bobby literally walked
around with that book for about a year
and there were a couple of friends of
mine from New York Alan Kaufman Bernard
Zukerman
I'm trying to think I know this one
other thing was Fred Wilson and the idea
was he would challenge he would go to
them at the club or wherever
for us and he'd hand them the book of
Boris Spassky games and say okay choose
a game and they would say oh that's key
somebody in 1970 Siegen and he recite
the game move for move so not only had
he memorized the game he had this like
picture-perfect clarity of Spassky and
the idea that he was prepared for Boris
Spassky was an understatement because he
was probably more conversant with
Boris's games than Boris himself was I
mean I forget my own games but somebody
who would memorize all the games you've
ever played that was just a remarkable
feat and we have world champion Magnus
Carlsen here with Maurice Ashley to talk
about today's game thanks Jen Magnus
with us Magnus this game you had today
it seemed like you were getting your
kind of position and then it all
evaporated what tell us would happen now
today was just awful the first three
games of mine were good then the game
yesterday was at least very interesting
or even though I lost it but today I was
just today was not real chance it was
just moving pieces around so what's
going on I don't know because yeah I
thought the first few days I was at
least playing okay yesterday was not a
great day but I thought apart from my
blunder at the end it wasn't that bad
but today I think we both didn't play
didn't play at a decent level when we
saw the game and you seemed to say
something to Veselin that completely
shocked him he kind of looked like did
you show him away he could have played
that was bad show them that you could
have played to work c5 there instead of
taking the pawn on f5 which I I saw that
immediately after I made my my last move
rook c8 and then then I would have had
to suffer and I would probably have been
successful in my quest to
for a loss Wow so you guys played the
King on King now we have a situation
that the rest of us are trying even to
figure out it has it ever happened
before especially at this high level we
have a player who was on a perfect score
one player half his number behind two
points behind and the rest of them at
minus one is this have you ever
experienced anything like this at this
level oh it's like Linares 2001 I think
when Gary had plus plus it was six
player around Robin Gary had plus five
and the rest of - one great memory good
one to catch but well hopefully things
will change but you know Fabiano's
playing he's playing proper chess he's I
mean he's winning his games in style and
right now the rest of us can only marvel
at what he's doing and aspire to do the
same one day wow that's that's a frank
admission
Nakamura has a different way of viewing
this particular problem he says I just
have to beat him and he feels pretty
confident he's as a good record against
him and then LaVon said it looks like we
all have to gang up on him you you take
what are you what is your take on those
two statements guys that are not ganging
up on me for one so yeah I mean
obviously if you want to win the
tournament you have to be Fabiano white
or black but right now for myself I just
need to to get back on track it started
out pretty well with two good black
games - well played Ross and now the two
white games have been a complete
disaster so I just need to yeah need to
regroup and it's still a long way
through well thanks so much for joining
us and best of luck with the rest of
their year thank you with world champion
Magnus Khurana like the rest of us
marveling at how far beyond
Rana is playing guys we were talking
about Magnussen is try wit that was
nicely done
we could all aspire to play of course he
wants in the beginning nothing on him
because that means he's winning the
tournament precisely so well if somebody
had told me that after four rounds a
player would be lapping the field
I wouldn't it I would have said well
it's obviously Magnus so this is really
really so remarkable it's we just I'm in
awe as we said earlier today fabulous
Faviana although I'm still a fan of mr.
perfect that one that's mine my big four
nicknames yeah yeah nice and let's take
a look and see what we got here in terms
of the standing Oh tomorrow's matches
rather so we've got Nakamura playing
against a Fabiano karamaneh Nakamura is
ready to go I've got a good score let's
make it even better that's what he said
and as for standings let's take a look I
think you know who's at the top if
you've been watching the show at all
he's not 5 ya know camerado with 4
points 2 points ahead of his nearest
rival Maxime bashir the grab MBL and
look at that rating go
meanwhile Levon Aronian he heard
Nakamura to Paolo and Carlson all tied
for last with a one and a half points
we have a final comment for Maurice
actually about a today's continuingly
exciting developments incredible I made
a slip baron called Magnus Magnus
Caruana
and his response cool customer he said
right now that's high praise incredible
situation Fabiano is impressing all of
us there's nothing else to say about
this tournament right now except Fabiano
Fabiano Fabiano I mean he is fabulous
his play has been just majestic and we
are seeing something special Magnus
Carlsen did say with his amazing memory
oh yeah Kasparov 9th 2001 Linares
started off five and oh that opportunity
will come to Caruana tomorrow we'll be
right here checking it out because this
is something simply amazing you see once
every 13 years pretty astonishing guys
that's right I mean I just goes to show
Magnus Carlsen not just memory just hard
work that guy knows his stuff yes he
does and he has those games memorized I
mean I remember watching a little
documentary of him where he was he was
quote he was looking at a position and
he had the identifying that's just the
right move but also where with the
demand hey the players the year that was
played and so on and he did it yeah yeah
so is Fabiano gonna continue tearing up
this field you're gonna want to check
out a pregame show tomorrow we start at
150 Central Standard Time here in st.
Louis come on down in person if you can
if you can't make sure to keep your eyes
peeled to the computer and that'll be
250 Eastern Time we'll see you tomorrow
for another fabulous taste test